The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: One of the cutest
little data structures
that was ever invented
is called the heap.
And we're going to use
the heap as an example
implementation of
a priority queue.
And we'll also use heaps to
build a sorting algorithm,
called heap sort,
that is very, very
different from either
insertion sort or merge sort.
And it has some nice properties
that neither insertions sort
nor merge sort have.
But what I want to
do is get started
with motivating the
heap data structure,
regardless of whether you're
interested in sorting or not.
So the notion of a
priority queue, I think,
makes intuitive
sense to all of you.
It's essentially
a structure that
implements a set S of elements.
And each of these elements
is associated with the key.
And as you can imagine, a
priority queue is something
where you queue
up for something,
you want to buy something,
you want to sell something.
You have certain
priorities assigned to you,
and you want to pick the maximum
priority or the min priority.
You want to be able to
delete it from the queue.
You want to be able to insert
things into this queue.
You want to be able to change
priorities in the queue.
So all of these operations
are interesting operations
that should run fast, and
for some definition of fast.
Obviously we are interested
in the asymptotic complexity
definition of fast.
In that case, we'll be saying
does this operation run
an order n time, order
log n time, et cetera.
So in general, I think
for the next few lectures,
you're going to see a
specification of data structure
in terms of the operations
that the data structure should
perform.
And those of you who have
taken six double O five,
you'll see that it's basically
an abstract data type that's
associated with
these operations.
So it's a spec for the
abstract data type.
In six double O
five, you had really
spent a lot of time on
asymptotic complexity,
or the efficiency of operations
on the abstract data type.
Here, in double O six,
you'll specify this ADT,
and specify the set of
operations or methods
in the ADT.
And we'll talk about whether
these are order end complexity
log end complexity, and compare
and contrast different ADTs.
So today's ADT is a heap.
And what is the
set of operations
that we'd like to perform
on a priority queue?
So we can use that to motivate
the development of the heap.
And those are, insert s x.
So you have a set of
elements s, and you
want to be able to insert
element x into set s.
You want to be able
to do max of s, which
is return the element of
s with the largest key.
And different from
max of s is extract
max of x, which not only returns
the element with the largest
key, but also removes it from s.
So you have a queue, and
the person in the queue
was serviced, or the element
in the queue was serviced,
and then removed from the queue.
And finally you can
imagine changing
the priority of a particular
element x in the set s.
And this priority,
there's an associated key
as we have up there
with each element.
And that key is called a k.
And increase key s x k would
increase the value of x's key
to the new value k.
And k could correspond to,
it's just called increase.
Most of the time, you're
increasing the value
in maybe a particular
application.
You could have suddenly
a decrease key,
and you would have to know
what the previous value was.
And is just a matter
of exactly what
operation you want to perform.
You could call it update, or
increment, whatever you like.
I'm going to spend most
of the time here talking
about how you maintain a
rep invariant of this data
structure called the heap,
that allows you to do
these operations in
an efficient way.
And we'll talk about
what the efficiency is,
and we'll try to analyze the
efficiency of these algorithms
that we put up.
So let's talk about a heap.
A heap is an implementation
of a priority queue.
It's amazingly and
array structure,
except that you're
visualizing this array
as a nearly complete
binary tree.
And what does that mean exactly?
Well, the best way
to understand that
is by looking at an example.
We got 10 here, so.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So here's my array
of 10 elements.
And the elements are
16, 14, 10, 8, 7.
So some set of elements
that are in random order,
clearly not sorted, and
I'm looking at the indices,
and I'm looking at the elements.
I'm going to visualize this as
a nearly complete binary tree.
Is not a full binary
tree, because I only
have 10 elements
in it, and it would
have to have 15 elements to
be a complete binary tree.
And we want to be able to do
the general case of an arbitrary
size array, and so that's why
we have nearly complete here.
So what does it mean to
visualize this as a tree?
Well, index one is
the root of the tree,
and that item is
the value is 16.
And what I have are indices
2 and 3 are the children,
and 4, 5, 6, and 7 are
the children of 2 and 3.
And 8, 9, and 10 are
the children of 4 and 5,
in this case.
And so that's the
picture you want
to keep in your head for
the rest of this lecture.
Any time you see
an array, and you
say we're going to be
looking at the heap
representation of the array,
the picture on the right
tells you what the
heap looks like.
And so that I'm not going
to fill in all of these.
You can, but I'll do a couple.
So you have 10 here,
and 8, 7, et cetera.
So that's a heap structure.
So what's nice about
this heap structure,
is that you'll have tree
representation of an array,
and that lets you do a
bunch of interesting things.
What do you get out
of this visualization?
Well, the root of the
tree is the first element
corresponding to i equals 1.
The parent of i is i over 2.
The left child of i is 2i.
And the right child
of i is 2i plus 1.
So that's essentially what
this mapping corresponds to.
Now on top of that, this is
just what a heap corresponds to.
We're going to have
particular types of heaps
that we'll call
max-heaps and min-heaps.
And as you can imagine,
max-heaps and min-heaps
have additional properties
on top of the basic
keep structures.
So this is essentially
a definition of a heap.
Now I'm going to define what
the max-heap property is.
And the max-heap property
says that the key of a node
is greater than or equal to
the keys of its children.
OK, that's it.
It's obviously
recursive, in the sense
that you have to have this true
for every node in the tree.
And when you get down to
the leaves of the tree,
they're not children
corresponding to the leaves,
So that's a trivial property.
But at higher levels, you're
going to have children,
and you have to check that.
So if you look at
this example here,
maybe I should fill
this whole thing out.
A have eight and seven
here, and six would be nine.
And I have three over here,
and then two, four, one.
So we can look at this
and check whether it
has the max-heap
property or not.
Does it have the
max-heap property?
This heap?
Yeah.
All you have to do is
look at these nodes.
one, two, three indices,
index four, five, six, but you
don't have to look
at six and seven,
because they don't
have any children.
But you could shop
with five here,
and you look at the
children, and there you go.
To the parent is greater
than or equal to either
of its children, or its only
child, in the case of node
five.
And so you have the
max-heap property.
So fairly
straightforward property.
And you can imagine defining
the min-heap property
in an equivalent way.
Just replace the greater
than or equal to,
with less than or equal to.
So right off the
bat, what operation
is going to be trivially
performed on a max-heap?
This is kind of
trivial question.
Yep.
Just finding the
biggest element.
Exactly right.
The max operation.
Now, what about extract max?
Is that trivially
performed on a max-heap?
No.
What do I mean by that?
When you say, max is
trivially performed,
what it means is that
you can return the max,
you can find the maximum
element, or a maximum element,
and you obviously
don't modify the heap.
And the heap stays the same,
so it stays a max-heap.
In general, when we talk
about data structures,
and this goes back to
rep invariance, which
I've mentioned
already, you typically
want to maintain
this rep invariant.
And so the rep invariant of our
data structure, in this case,
is a max-heap property.
OK.
So we want to maintain
the max-heap property
as we modify the heat.
So if you go from
one heap to another,
you start at the max-heap, you
want to end with the max-heap.
It makes perfect sense,
because in one of the simplest
things that you want to
do in a priority queue,
is you want to be able to
create a priority queue,
and you want to be able to run
extract max on the priority
queue, over and over.
And what that means, is that
you take the max element, you
delete it, take the next
max element, delete it,
and so on and so forth.
And there you go.
It's a bit of a
preview here, but you
could imagine that if
you did that, you would
get a sorted list of
elements in decreasing order.
So you see the
connection to sorting,
because you could imagine
that once we have this heap
structure, and we can maintain
the max-heap property,
that we could continually
run extract max on it.
And if you could build extract
max in an efficient way,
you might have a fantastic
sorting algorithm.
So, the big question
that really remains,
is how do we maintain
the max-heap property
as we modify the heap?
And the other question,
which I haven't answered
is-- this array that turns
out it was a max-heap,
but it's quite
possible that I have
a trivial example of an array.
In fact, let me make this one.
That is not a max-heap.
It's not a max-heap, it's
not a min-heap, it's neither.
Right? it's just a heap.
So if I just
transform, or visualize
I should say, this array as a
heap, I don't have a max-heap,
I don't have a min-heap.
So if I'm very interested
in sorting, and I am,
there's this
another thing that's
sort of missing here
that we have to work on,
which is how are we going
to build a max-heap out
of an initially unsorted array.
Which may or may not
turn into a max-heap.
This trivially happened to
be exactly the right thing,
because I picked it, and
it turned into a max-heap
just by visualizing it.
But it's quite
possible that you have
arrays that are input to
your sorting algorithm that
look like that.
OK, so let's dive
into heap operations.
I'm going to have spend
some time describing to you
a bunch of different methods
that you would call on a heap.
And all of these
methods are going
to have to maintain
our representation
invariant of the
max-heap property.
So what are the heap
operations that we
have to implement and
analyze the complexity for?
Well, we're going to
have build-max-heap
which produces a max-heap
from an arbitrary or unordered
array.
So somehow I got to turn
this into, for example,
four, two, one.
Which is in effect,
sorting this array.
Or changing the order.
Maybe not fully sorting
it, but changing the order.
So that's what I have to
do, and build-max-heap
is going to have to do that.
In order to do build-max-heap,
the first procedure
that I'm going to describe to
you, is called max-heapify.
Heapify.
Sounds a little
strange, but I guess
you can -ify pretty
much anything.
So you correct a
single violation
of the heap property in a
subtree, a subtree's root.
And I'll explain what I mean
by that in just a minute.
So max-heapify is the
fundamental operation
that we have to understand here.
And we're going to
use it over and over.
What it does, is
take something that
is not a heap, not a max-heap.
When I say not a
heap from now on,
pretend that I'm
saying not a max-heap.
We're only going to be
talking about max-heaps
for the rest of this lecture.
What max-heapify does,
is take something
that is not quite a max-heap.
It can't take
anything arbitrary.
It's going to take
something where there's
a single violation of
the max-heap property
at some subtree of this
heap that is given to you,
and there's a single
violation of that.
And it's going to fix that.
And we need to be able
to do this recursively
at different levels
to go build a max-heap
from an unordered array.
Then once you have
that, you can do
all sorts of things like insert
and extract max, and heap sort,
and so on and so forth.
So let's take a look at
max-heapify using an example.
I'm not going to write
pseudocode for max-heapify.
I'll run through an example, and
the pseudocode is in the notes.
The big assumption,
and you think
of this as a precondition,
for running max-heapify,
is the trees rooted at left
i and right i are max-heaps.
So max-heapify is going
to look like a comma i.
a is simply the array,
and i is the index.
Max-heapify is
willing to, you're
allowed to crash and
not do anything useful
if this precondition is
violated in max-heapify.
But if the precondition is
true, then what you have to do
is, you have to return
a max-heap correcting
this violation.
That's the contract.
So let's take a
look at an example.
I think what I want to
do is start over here.
I want you to see all
of the steps here.
So we'll take a simple
example, and we'll
run through max-heapify.
And let's take a
look at 16, four--
I'm just going to draw the
indices for this first example,
and then I won't bother.
So there you go.
Is this a max-heap?
No.
Because right here,
I've got a problem.
4 is less than 14, therefore
I have a violation.
And so, if you look at the
call max-heapify A comma 2,
this is an index 2,
and all you have to do
is to look at this subtree.
And what you need to
be satisfied in order
to run max-heapify, is that the
subtrees of nodes index two,
which is this four
node, are max-heaps.
And if you go look below, you
see that this is a max-heap
and that's a max-heap.
Most of the time,
by the way, you
will be sort of
working bottom up,
and that's why this is
going to make sense.
This will all work
out, because leaves
are by definition max-heaps.
Because you don't have
to check anything.
When you put two
leaves together,
and you want to create a tree
like that, or a heap like that,
then you run max-heapify.
And then when you have a
couple different max-heaps,
and you want to
put them together
to make it a bigger max-heap,
you'd have run max-heapify.
So that's the way
it's going to work.
So you want to do a
max-heapify A comma 2.
One of the things that's
going to be important,
not in this example, but
when we get to sorting,
is that we want to know what
the size of the heap is.
And in this case,
the heap size is 10.
So, what does max-heapify do?
Well, all max-heapify does
is exchanges elements.
And so, if you looked at
the code for max-heapify,
and you walked through it,
this is what it would do.
You're going to
look at 4 and 14,
and it's going to
say, OK, I'm going
to look at both my children.
And I'm going to go ahead and
exchange with the bigger child.
So I'm going to
exchange AA[2] with AA[4].
And what that would do is,
take this, make this 4,
and make this 14.
And that would be step one.
And then when you
get to this point,
recursively, you'd realize
that the max-heap property
at this level is violated.
And so you would go ahead and
call max-heapify A comma 4.
And when that happens,
that call happens,
you're going to look at the
two children corresponding
to this little subtree
there, and you're
going to do the exchange.
You're going to have
8 here and 4 here.
So you would exchange
AA[4] with AA[8].
And now you're done, so
there's no more calls.
So, fairly straightforward.
It's actually not any more
complicated than this.
There may be many steps.
What might happen is that you'd
have to go all the way down
to the leaves.
And in this case, you
went a couple of steps,
and then you got to stop.
But obviously, you
could have a large heap,
and it could take
a bunch of time.
So, what is the
complexity of max-heapify?
Anybody?
Yeah.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Ultimately,
potentially,
if the tree is
totally upside down,
you could potentially switch
every node to make it order in.
PROFESSOR: Every node
to make it order in.
Everybody, anybody.
Do you have a different answer?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
PROFESSOR: Why?
Why is it log n.
AUDIENCE: Because I think
the worst case scenario,
all of your-- the
worst case scenario you
would have [INAUDIBLE]
on the left-hand side,
[INAUDIBLE] right-hand side.
And it would be skewed.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So you're
arguing that the solution
to the recurrence gives you
a logarithmic complexity.
Alright.
Not quite.
There's an easier
way of arguing this.
this Yeah.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So what is the complexity?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
PROFESSOR: Log n.
Great.
Excellent.
Definitely worth a cushion.
Missed you by that much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: It's pretty
soft, by the way.
Right.
OK.
So, if I hit somebody,
they get a cushion.
OK.
That's exactly right.
Thanks for that description.
So, first off, there's
two important aspects
to this argument.
The first thing is,
that we're visualizing
this is a nearly
complete binary tree.
It is not an unbalanced tree.
Alright?
We'll talk about unbalanced
trees and balanced trees
in the next couple of lectures.
But the visualization of a heap
is a nearly complete binary
tree.
And, in fact, if
you had 15 elements,
it would be a
perfect binary tree.
So the good news is, that the
height of this visualization
tree is bounded by log n.
That's the good news.
And you want to
exploit that good news
by creating algorithms
that go level by level.
If you can do that, you're going
to have logarithmic complexity
algorithms.
So that was one aspect of it.
The other aspect of it,
is the key assumption
that we're making, with
respect to build-max-heap,
that there was a
single violation.
It is true that the answer that
was given that was order n,
would be a problem.
I could set it up so that's
actually the right answer,
if I did not have this
assumption-- where
do I have that here-- assume
that the trees rooted at left i
and right i are max-heaps.
So maybe that's what
you were thinking.
But this is a key assumption.
This is going back
and like making
connections between classes.
This is a precondition
that makes
the algorithm more efficient.
Makes the implementation easier.
And this precondition
essentially
says that you have to just go
down and do a number of steps,
that's the number of levels in
the tree, which is logarithmic.
So that's the story here
with the max-heapify.
It's order log n, in
terms of complexity.
That's the number of
steps that you have.
And it's a basic building block
for all of the other algorithms
that we look at for the rest
of this lecture, and in section
tomorrow.
Let's talk about how you
would take max-heapify and use
it to do build-max-heap.
So the first step
now, let's say that we
want to go and get a
nice sorting algorithm.
We don't like insertion sort,
we don't like merge sort.
We'd like to get a
heap-based sorting algorithm.
One of the things that
we need to do, as I said,
is to take an unordered
array, and turn it
into a max-heap, which is
a non-trivial thing to do.
And once we do that, we can
do this extract-max deal
to sort the array.
So the first step is, we
want to convert an array A 1
through n into a max-heap.
And the key word
here is max-heap,
because every array can
be visualized as a heap.
And I am going write the
pseudocode for build-max-heap,
because it's just
two lines of code.
And that's about the limit
of a size of a program
I can really understand,
or explain, I should say.
And this is what it looks like.
Alright.
that's it.
Build-max-heap says go from
i equals n, by 2, down to 1.
Max-heapify A of i.
So someone explain to me why
I can start with n over 2,
and why I'm going down to 1.
Yep.
I saw you first.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Leaves are good.
Leaves are good.
I'll let you go on in a second.
Leaves are good, because if you
look at elements A of n over 2,
plus 1 through n,
are all leaves.
That's a good observation.
And this is true for any array.
It doesn't matter what n is.
Doesn't have the power of
2, or 2 [INAUDIBLE] minus 1,
or anything like that.
And leaves a good,
because they automatically
satisfy the backseat property.
Continue.
AUDIENCE: OK. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Beautiful.
I won't hit anybody here.
So that's it.
The reason this works,
is because you're
calling max-heapify
multiple times,
but every time you call it,
you satisfy the precondition.
And the leaves are
automatically max-heaps.
Then you start with n over 2.
You are going to see two
leaves as your children
for the n over 2 node, right?
I mean, just pick
an example here.
Our 2 is an A of 5, right?
You're out here.
In this case, depending
on the value of n,
you may have either two
children, or just one child.
And you have one child.
But regardless of
that, that's going
to be a max-heap,
because it's a leaf.
And so you'll have
two leaves, and you
need to put them together.
And that's a fairly
straightforward process
of attaching the
leaves together.
You might have to do a swap,
based on what the element is.
One operation and you
get a little small tree,
that's a max-heap.
And then you do a
bunch of other things
that all work on leaves,
because n over 2 minus 1
is probably also
going to have leaves
as it's children, given
the large value of n.
There will be a
bunch of things where
you work on these level
one nodes, if you will,
that all have
leaves as children.
And then you work on
the level two nodes,
and so on and so forth.
And as I said before,
you're working your way up,
and you're only
working with max-heaps
as your left child
and your right child.
That make sense?
If you do that, and this
is a fairly straightforward
question, if you do
a straightforward
analysis of this, what is the
complexity of build-max-heap?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's order.
Order n log n.
Now, this is through
a simple analysis.
Now I'm going to
give you a chance
to tell me if you can
do better than that.
Or not.
In terms of analysis.
It's a subtle question.
It's a subtle question,
that I'm asking.
I'm saying, this is
the algorithm, alright?
I don't want you to
change the algorithm,
but I want you to
change your analysis.
The analysis that
you just did was,
you said, I got
[INAUDIBLE] n steps here,
because it's n by 2 steps.
Looks like each of the
steps is taking log n time.
So that's n log n.
And I was careful.
I put big O here.
OK?
Because that's an upper bond.
So that's a valid answer.
Can you do better?
Can you do a better
analysis-- and I'll
let you go first-- can you do
a better analysis that somehow
gives me better complexity?
AUDIENCE: I think you
bring it to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
How?
AUDIENCE: So each node get a
maximum of two [INAUDIBLE].
So, for some n, there will be a
constant number of comparisons
to max-heapify that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's hard to explain.
You're on the right track.
Absolutely on the right track.
So it turns out that,
and I'll do this,
it's going to take
a few minutes here,
because I write some things out.
You have to sum up a bunch of
arithmetic series, and so on.
So it's a bit unfair to have
to speak out the answer,
but the correct
answer, in fact, is
that this is order n complexity.
This algorithm
that I put up here,
if you do a careful
analysis of it,
you can get order n out of it.
And we'll do this
careful analysis.
And I'll tell you
why it's order n,
in terms of a hand
wavy argument.
A hand wavy argument is
that you're doing basically,
obviously no work
for the leaves.
But you're not
even counting that,
because you're
starting with n over 2.
But when you look at
the n over 2 node,
it's essentially one
operation, or two operations,
in whichever way you
count, to build max-heap.
And so for that
first level of nodes,
it's exactly one operation.
The first level that
are above the leaves.
For the next level, you may
be doing two operations.
And so there is an
increase in operations
as you get higher and higher up.
But there are fewer
and fewer nodes as you
at higher and higher up, right?
Because there's only one node
that is the highest level node.
The root node.
That node has logarithmic
number of operations,
but it's only one node.
The ones down on the bottom
have a constant number
of operations.
So I'll put all of this
down, and hopefully you'll
be convinced by the time
we've done some math here,
or some arithmetic here, but
you can quantify what I just
said fairly easily,
as long as you're
careful about the counting
that we have to do.
So this is really,
truly counting.
Analysis has a lot
to do with counting.
And we're just being more
careful with the counting,
as opposed to this
straightforward argument that
wasn't particularly
careful with the counting.
So let's take a look at
exactly this algorithm.
And I want to make
an observation.
Which is what I just did,
but I'd like to write it out.
Where we say, max-heapify
takes constant time
for nodes that are one
level above leaves.
And, in general,
order L time for nodes
that are L levels
above the leaves.
That's observation number one.
Observation number
two is that we
have n over 4 nodes
that, give or take one,
depending on the value of n.
I don't want to get hung
up on floors and ceilings.
And in any case,
we're eventually
going to get an
asymptotic result,
so we don't have to
worry about that.
But we have n over four nodes
with level one, n over 8
with level two.
And 1 node with log
n, sort of the log n
level, which is the root.
So this is decrease in
terms of nodes as the work
that you're doing increases.
And that's the careful
accounting that we have to do.
And so all I have to do now
to prove to you that this
is actually an
order and algorithm,
is to write a little
summation that sums up
all of the work across
these different levels.
And so the total amount
of work in the 4 loop
can be summed as n divided
by 4, times 1, times c.
So this sum, I have
one level here,
and I'm going to do some
constant amount of work
for that one level.
So I'm just going
to put c out there,
because eventually I can
take away the c, right?
That's the beauty
of asymptotics.
So we don't need to
argue about how much work
is done at that one
level, how many swaps,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the fact is that
these n over four nodes
are one level above the leaves.
That's what's key.
And then I have n over 8 times
2c, plus n over 16 times 3c,
plus 1 times log of n c.
I've essentially written
in an arithmetic expression
exactly what I have
observed on the board above.
Stop me if you have questions.
Now I'm going to set--
just to try and make
this a little easier to
look at, and easy to reason
about-- I'm going to set
n over 4 to 2 raised to k,
and I'm going to simplify.
I'm just pulling
out certain things,
and this thing is going
to translate to c times 2
raised to k, times 1,
divided by 2 raised to 0,
2 divided by 2 raised to 1,
3 divided by 2 raised to 2,
et cetera, k plus 1
divided by 2 raised to k.
Now, if that was
confusing, raise your hand,
but it's essentially identical
given the substitution and sort
of just applying the
distributive law.
And the reason I did
this, is because I
wanted you to see the arithmetic
expression that's in here.
Now we do know that 2 raised
to k is n over four, of course.
But if you look at this
expression that's inside here,
what is this expression?
Anyone?
Can you bound this expression?
Someone?
For the cushion.
Remember your arithmetic
series from wherever it was.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You know better than I. I guess
you took those courses more
recently, but what
happens with that?
Those of you who
have calculators,
I mean, you could plug
that in, and answer that.
No one?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You know that it's
going to merge to two.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly
what I was looking for.
Essentially, well, it's not
quite two, because you have a 1
here, and you have a 1 here,
but you're exactly right.
I mean, two is good.
It's asymptotic,
I mean, come on.
I'm not going to complain
about two versus three, right?
So the point is it's
bounded by a constant.
It's bounded by a constant.
This is a convergent series
and it's bounded by a constant.
And we can argue about
what the constant is.
It's less than three.
And it doesn't matter
of k goes to infinity.
And you want k to
go to infinity,
but it doesn't matter if
k is small or k is large,
this is bounded by a constant.
And that's the key observation.
What do we have left?
We have a constant there.
We have a c, which
is a constant,
and we have a 2 raised
to k, which is really n.
So there you go.
There you have your
theta n complexity.
Now I can say theta n,
because I know it's theta n.
But big O of n, theta
n, that's what it is.
So that's what I'd say
is subtle analysis.
Clearly a little more
complicated than anything
we've done so far, and let me
see if there are questions.
How many people got this?
I did too.
Someone who didn't get
it, ask a question.
What didn't you get?
What step would you
like me to repeat here?
Any particular step?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This thing here?
Right here?
OK, so you're not convinced
that this expression
got translated to
this expression.
So let me try and convince
you of that, alright?
So let's take a look
at each of the terms.
n by 4 is 2 raised to k.
I'm just looking at
this term and this term.
n by 4 is 2 raised to k.
c is c.
And I just wrote 1 as 1 divided
by 2 raised to 0, which is 1.
And the reason I
want you to do this,
is because I want to show you an
expression where in some sense,
this is the term that is the
summation for your expression.
If we just replace this,
you can write this out
as i equals 0 through k, I plus
1 divided by 2 raised to i.
That is the symbolic
form of this expression,
which came from here.
And then the argument
was made that this
is a convergent series and
is bounded by a constant.
That make sense?
Good.
So that's pretty neat, right?
I mean, you have the same
algorithm and, whala,
it suddenly got more efficient.
Doesn't always happen,
but that tells you
that you have to have
some care in doing
your analysis, because what
really happened here, was you
did a rudimentary analysis.
You said, this was order
log n, big O log n,
and you said this was theta
n, and you ended up with this.
But in reality, it's
actually a faster algorithm.
So that's the good news.
Build-max-heap can be
done in order n time.
Now in the time that I
have left, it turns out,
we are essentially all
the way to heaps sort.
Because all we
have to do is use,
once we have
build-max-heap, I'll
just write out the
code for heap sort,
and you can take a look
at examples in the notes.
The pseudocode, I should
say, for heap sort.
And it looks like this.
The first step that you
do is you build max-heap
from the unordered array.
Then you find the
maximum element AA[1].
All of this I've
said multiple times.
Now the key step is, you
could do extract max,
but one nice way
of handling this,
is to swap the elements
AA[n] with AA[1].
Let me write this
out and explain
exactly what that means.
Now the maximum element is
at the end of the array.
When you do the swap.
That's the one step
that I will have
to spend another minute on.
Now we discard node
n from the heap,
simply by decrementing
heap size.
So the heap becomes
n minus 1 in size
from n in the first iteration.
Now the new root after the
swap may violate max-heap,
we'll call it the
max-heap property,
but the children are max-heaps.
So that's the one node that
can possibly violate it.
So what that means, is we can
run max-heapify to fix this.
And that's it .
Once you do that, you
go back to that step.
So what's happened here exactly?
Well this part we spent
a bunch of time on.
element is the maximum
element, so you grab that.
And you know that's
a maximum element.
One way of doing it is to
use extract max, but rather
than doing extract max, which
I haven't explained to you,
you could imagine
that you go off
and you swap the top element
with the bottom element,
and then you discard it.
So here's a trivial
example, where
let's say I had 4, 2, and
1, which is a max-heap.
What would happen is you'd
say, I'm going to take 4
and I'm going swap it with 1.
And so you have, 1, 2, and 4.
Now four used to be AA[1], and
that's the maximum element,
and I'm just going to
delete it from the heap,
which means I'm going to end up
with a heap that looks like--
a heap, not a max-heap--
that looks like this.
And I write down 4 here.
4 is the first element
in my sorted array.
Now I look at 1 and
2, and 1 and 2 there's
obviously not a max-heap.
But I can run max-- I know
the child is a max-heap,
so I can run
max-heapify on this.
And what this turns
into is 2 and 1.
And at this point, I know
that the max is the root,
because I've run max-heapify
and I take 2 out,
and after this, it
becomes trivial.
But that's the
general algorithm.
So this whole thing
takes order n log n time,
because even though
build-max-heap
is order n and max
element is constant time,
swapping the elements
is constant time.
But running max-heapify
is order log n time,
and you have n steps.
So you have an order
n log n algorithm.
But the first step
was order n, which
is what we spent a
bunch of time on.
So I'll show you
examples in the notes,
and that will get
covered again in section.
I'll stick around for questions.
See you next time.